lizard League divide and conquer lizards
I mean kids stand down and surrender
giving redundant commands this doesn't
have to get any uglier than it already
is saying this when we all know how
dedicated the show is to animated Gore
dark queen not coming red Rush Martian
man's helping dark blood this banter
could and should have occurred before or
after the battle this is primarily here
to let the viewer know who is and isn't
coming to this dinner party I'm not
going to make it am I well given that we
haven't seen you at all in present day
Invincible I'm going to say your chances
aren't great Polly show will keep us in
suspense about why Nolan doesn't pursue
this car by suspense I mean it never
comes up again bring my specimen back
title of my sex tape driving without a
license plate we can take it from here
Mr Dr
brandworthy giving actual helpful
scientific facts for the ER doctors also
there's something to be said about how
the two doctors manag to spend more time
arguing than caring for their patient
who will die in a moment I think there's
a malpractice suit in here and it's
never pursued we all thought she was
gone but she she came back to us all on
her own we don't know how but she did
seems like y'all could have made a
better lie than that come up with some
medical explanation this is just one
step away from somehow Palpatine
returned are Samantha Eve Wilkins let
this be a lesson that a proper roll
commercials is just as much about the
tone of delivery as it is about uttering
the right petronis you got embarrassed
by your child staring at the floor kids
do way more embarrassing stuff than that
have you never seen a child with Tootsie
Roll stuffed into each nostril the
Periodic Table of no elements how in the
world is this painting missing it's
Christina oh she's not gifted she's just
weird you can be both never got the need
for characters to start dealing in
absolutes like a Sith every time a show
needs to drum up some tension Dr Brandy
worth thinks creepy stalking is
protecting a tactic that goes on far too
long and is way more successful than it
should have been in a perfect world he
gets arrested long before he even has
the opportunity to help Eve but he can
barely keep his skin on his bones damn
Lance reic is just such a commanding
presence whether he's checking assassins
into a hotel or running a top secret
military research division so here's a
sin for the universe for taking him away
from us too soon I want the ability to
change reality I want death on command I
want powerful beyond measure the inside
of a man's mind while he's thinking
about the Roman Empire somehow makes it
into the episode and if I don't see
something different soon you'd won the
two next forcing people to go to London
that's a fate worse than Boston but it's
still not Cleveland suck at Ohio her mom
pieces out just leaving her in the car
so she can forge a friendship for the
sole reason of tearing our hearts out
later in the episode negligent parenting
is responsible for all the saddest plot
points the reflection of the stop sign
changing colors is a very confusing
safety concern chaps they just want a
normal casid who does her piano lessons
and gets straight A and stuff that's
normal then I'm not normal and I am
absolutely completely and unequivocally
normal D freaks look at yourself letting
this abusive trash man survive omn man
alien invasions detonating houses weekly
super villains and more we let him take
Pluto and now Neptune has gotten the
boot too Uranus better watch its back
these special effects are doing little
to make math not math meanwhile on
Stargate change pack change back change
this works despite Eve having no idea
what she did in the first place there
was a fair chance the book turned into a
lobster roll after all that normal
people aren't supposed to be able to do
things like that oh F off show like
anyone's best friend would actually say
this instead of immediately asking them
to turn their pocket change into gold de
Bloons so they could buy everything like
that kid did in blank check remember to
write a thank you note to Aunt Penny
stealing your jokes from A Christmas
Story all of the universe is at your
fingertips and you transform this outfit
into a tank top and jeans guess you
think F superpowers are both wasted on
the young now that we know she can make
her clothes into whatever she wants was
there really any need for this first
iteration sup suit thing that Comics
think is a necessary part of character
development this whole scene is like
when Invincible first used his powers
but cooler but it's also now a cliche
why is stealing dogs because no one
gives a [__] about dogs have you met
anyone everyone loves dogs some people
love dogs more than they love other
people which I understand cuz they're
dogs buzz off Powerpuff did he really
think that was going to work on the
person who just flew in on a glowing
pink disc hard pass creep I'm not here
to hurt you this works on the person who
just flew in on a glowing pink disc and
now you eat out of dumpsters the
judgments of a person who's never found
themselves behind a crispy cream at
closing time sure the manager might
spray you with a hose or throw a bug
bomb but if you're strong enough it's
totally worth it nice soul patch bro
thanks makes your face extra punchable
hey not nice the name's kill Cannon evil
fight kill Cannon not because she has to
but because it's more fun than just
making his helmet really heavy even
though that worked really well on the
dog robbers also making a discount
Captain America shield instead of
turning his cannon into a bubble gun a
marshmallow gun or a gun that shoots out
affirming compliments about people's
personalities you're just not made for
this I literally was Adam Eve would be
excellent at TV sins
Samantha how do you keep doing that I
have a lot of time on my hands but do
you have super speed too because you're
keeping up with someone literally flying
around the city trade you a burger for
some answers if you can transmute matter
do you ever really need to go to a
burger Mart ever again fall back and um
former perimeter or
something we'll fall back and former
perimeter stealing your jokes from The
Avengers and Star Wars who are you you
don't know one would assume that's why
she asked the question you're Phase 1
Phase 2 phase three phase 4 Phase 5 each
attempt less successful than the last
but all one big happy family Marvel
being honest about the trajectory of the
MCU while bragging about its continuity
somehow makes it into the episode okay
this fight ising amazing emotionally
brutal and brings the full promise of
what I've come to love about Invincible
even my grumpy ass has to take this in
off I don't doubt Eve can do all this in
her head but who taught her how to fight
like this having the ability to change
matter is one thing but learning how to
dodge Counterattack and all this other
sh without any training seems a bit
far-fetched Eve will now use her Pink
Lantern powers to create an Iron Man
suit and I'm beginning to wonder if all
of reality is derivative of all the
amazing abilities Eve has I'm not sure
which one should have stopped all her
bones from breaking when she hit that
barrier I'll buy it just because she
seems pretty all powerful but a little
help in understanding the limits of this
character would be nice what are you
doing we're going to die it'll be worth
it to see the life trend from your
perfect eyes siblings I guess she's the
one who can change the simulation as she
sees fit honestly seems like in choosing
the name adim me she accidentally
alluded to the wrong Testament I have to
send the cops for not setting up a
perimeter only because they said they
were setting up a perimeter we fall back
in former perimeter come on guys don't
make promises you can't keep he could
barely keep his skin on his bone sitting
in the lab what makes him suddenly able
to withstand a giant explosion and walk
out like nothing
happened I call [__] on this road
being traversible in any way that would
have allowed Brandy Worth to get here in
a car for all the heroes this show is
established not a single one shows up to
the disaster that this highway has
become they can change into things alter
their bodies I can't do any of that they
wanted you to be a perfect weapon but
even I have a conscience you two do not
have time for this discussion they
killed themselves trying to hurt me well
actually you killed some of them and Dr
brandworthy was the only one who
technically killed
himself giving the doctor the old the
blunt for scen transition also we see
him being knocked out so it's weird to
wake up here from Eve's perspective
these restraints are so easily defeated
the show tried to rationalize it based
on I told you those restraints were
theoretical and not the fact that the
show needed to be wrapped up in 5
minutes oh God she's alive technically
alive we didn't get her back up in
running at time to save her from massive
brain damage but well we both know
she'll be had one use anyway damn this
episode's depressing I mean it gives
Adam's character a ton of new depth but
damn you murdered my whole family Eve
calm down does he really think such a
command would work and where have you
been being angry with this hat on hey
like it or not we're the only family
you've got I know omn man was a
homicidal maniac but for 17 years of
Mark's life he was still a better father
than what Eve got that's how much I hate
Eve's adopted dad is she a generative AI
otherwise I don't know how she so
quickly came up with what her siblings
would have looked like if they were born
healthy and
normal Dad look I'm going to
[Music]
be your foster parents are kind of dicks
huh I'm not going to make it am
I I can feel it are you just going to
stand there do something I made you
Samantha you banged mom but you didn't
listen to me you think you could do
these things but you just can't
Nemo you like crabby patties don't you
Squidward fall back and um former
perimeter or something we don't need
so-called superheroes what Empire City
needs is more cops and the
Hooters go to sleep go to sleep go to
sleep I'm sorry Start I don't feel so
good yeah I'm thinking on back well you
are back Dr brendy W